caught into Sonya time is it now 7:30
okay welcome everybody and the emergency
infatuation a happy hour technically
apologies for absence captured George
are you
hope members attending a short wooden
minutes at the meeting held in the 5th
of June to be happy that sign that off
deck relation to interest
and just remind you if it does come up
during the course of making matters
referred to the exactly the report smoke
committees to item six the big events
members you'll probably remember that
active work around the last resting
place of the beagle dates back almost 20
years to the early part of this
millennium when the University of
Andrews University in st. Andrew rather
and Professor Robert fresco professor
colleague will interface became involved
in trying to discover whether the
remains of the beagle are still in
collection reach and council has been
involved for much of that time but has
been particularly active since about
2015 and it finally became a more
focused project a little over a year ago
so to recap the 11th of May next year is
the bicentennial of HMS beagles launch
and the event is planned to commemorate
both that event but also celebrates the
role of that ship in watch for district
history the event is planned to be the
inaugural event of discover 2020 and is
so and so the key part of building the
district profiles a tourist destination
as part of our emerging tourism strategy
in order to build a visitor
for me it's also a integral part of
ethics 2020s year of science and
creativity which is a commission bias
its County Council Johnson City Council
and Anglia Ruskin University to
commemorate the British Science Festival
coming to Essex for the very first time
from Coventry and the Essex 2020
festival will delivery an Essex wide
year-long program of science technology
engineering maths arts and maths steam
events exhibitions projects and curated
opportunities as a campaign to raise
awareness and enable audiences to engage
with programme of activities and
particularly to raise the profile of
ethics as a forward-thinking County
we're economy size thrives and the
unites communities that will have
national and indeed international
exposure and we're very much part of the
the lineup that Essex is putting forward
the vehicle store is also ignited a
number of cultural interventions by
other organizations in which will
benefit the district
the Essex cultural diversity project
which is an Arts Council sponsored
project has commissioned artwork to take
place between now and March of next year
commission to artists to take a
photographic portraiture of people to
their journey so the the theme of
exploration and discovery is repeated as
part about commissioned English Heritage
have made contact with me to renew
interest in archaeological observations
and at the the people
site and they'll be bringing a team and
their press later on this month and
visit England have included us in the
heart of their England's creative Coast
project which is across the whole of the
geography of cellar and there's a press
launch tomorrow and public communication
is involving so I can't say any more
than that but we're very much a game
part of that public interest so there's
no doubt that beagle story has created a
lot of interest and it's no doubt that
this event will probably will be one of
the biggest that we've ever put on and
we've already identified a number of
prestigious partners who want to be part
of the event and we are about to start
beginning to identify potential sponsors
logistics are sketched out with the view
to putting in place a final draft event
management plan flying October and
that's with a view to to getting them
approved by Christmas which will enable
us to begin ticket sales in February of
next year and that that essentially is
is our critical path around which other
work streams of currently being mapped
out and will be reported back to this
executive as a silver project by the
project management office when the
project was first mooted as I say that
I've probably just over a year or so ago
in how the instruction was that it
should be cost neutral to the council
and consequently its proposed to be
funded through sponsorship grant and
ticket sales and the latter make up
seventy percent of the costs recovered
please there are some risks around this
not the least of which is demand risk
and
the price of the tickets is modeled on
an estimation of 2,000 visitors per day
and it also assumes that 10% of the
tickets are sold that's unusual for a
event of this type because the price is
based on full cost recovery rather than
an element of profit and for most
commercial event organizers in the
margin that they build into the ticket
price provides additional catalyst
irrespective of risk mitigation so
ticket prices have been benchmarked
against other local attractions and hold
up reasonably well especially because of
the uniqueness of this offer and the
variety attractions which will be
available on site however it is fair to
say I think it's at the top end where I
would like it to be and the plan is to
attract additional sponsorship which we
can then pass straight on to the bottom
line and reduce ticket sales so that's
really why I'm asking to bring the
matter back to this this meeting in
September by which time I should be in
position then to have crystallize out
the event management plan and find and
crystallize out further detail the
budget but by far the biggest cost in
the logit is the park-and-ride scheme
and this is the only way that we can
safely get the numbers of people that we
need on and off the site safely there is
no onsite parking and creating one set
parking it's not
a health and safety reasons and public
transport simply doesn't service that
particular part of the world so we will
operate a number of clock and my schemes
along the route linking eating with
local hospitality businesses such as the
cherry tree the plant sale the anchor
our canoe Dhin and to try and end a
short under Shapland of I should say
also to to ensure that local businesses
can benefit from the additional football
that will be passing through the
transport plan is still in draft
I took Essex highways along the route
this morning an opportunity to Wallasey
so they've been there already in the
neutral terms of understanding how the
hot night skiing will work the event
will be ticketed so the allocation of
POD white car foxes is linked entirely
to the issue of tickets and and security
on site at sponsor it's also links
faculty
so as I say the budget at the moment
doesn't include any sponsorship of the
infrastructure or the transporter didn't
think we can do to reduce that cost will
be passed back on to the customer
through a juicer ticket prices and
that's why I'm suggesting 30 comes back
to this at this meeting but I do you
need this meetings permission to take
this forward as an event now to start so
that I can start to actively promote it
and particularly start attracting
sponsors is gaining lots of interest
already and and but I'll need to begin
things like procurement activities for
some costs because we're less than a
year to go into the event now I think
all the other information is in the
report and listen and that's exactly
what are the questions no members
questions
squattin looking at the report you've
got doesn't seem to be very much anybody
sizing me because banners and posters
temporary site signage assembly off-site
sign entry strategy so there is a
marketing and communication structure
marketing and communication strategy and
stakeholder engagement it is an
extremely lingual to sponsorship because
we will be selling advertising as a
gaming advertising as part of a
sponsorship approach the websites don't
forget exists as do the social media
sites already fir discover 2020 we also
have the council's existing routes to to
impress we will also meet accessing
ethics 2020s routes to press including
visit ethics which were remember and was
there doing a lot of work in Mayflower
400 next year as well so they're already
on their radar that so we are talking to
piggyback other people's routes to
audience but there is some budget
because Greater Anglia we were a
transport partner with with us have said
that they will give over the poster
space on the platforms essentially
between Rockford and Raley and we're
going to ask
students to design a predator
competition which will then be on the
winners of would hardly be on the
platforms and then with those persons
they'd be carefully being displayed in
you know the public faces - that's all
thank you
I notice obviously you're going to be
trying to to get 2,000 visitors Dyk now
but just coming on one thing they're
just interesting for me or a couple of
things was on 3.7 4.1 which is the
creation of the computer generated 3d or
people which can be viewed by your
smartphone or tablet have you in the
pipeline in regards to app that can be
acquired that you actually create an app
specifically for this so that if people
are going around the gorge people will
have a smartphone to be able to have
something that could give a coverage of
where they are in various points so that
they can actually connect up and see the
various things I mean I'm thinking of a
huge project that I went to which is the
Mary Rose which you actually see people
in action on board the ship when you see
the various things it was just something
that
looking to actually do within this
generation of seeing it as an exciting
part of this project
so the the the CGI is subject to
separate funding I'm in the process of
putting together an application to the
National Lottery Heritage Fund the
artist humanist on this work before has
done something similar and worked on the
University of Southampton in respect of
the grass year which was in refits
flagship imaging core and the idea is to
create a 3d schematic from the available
blueprints and then to put it on to a
panorama the conditions of national
lottery applications are that it has to
use open source software it has to be
publicly available and my understanding
from the from the creator is that that
is achievable and will be posted we are
hoping that project to a gain additional
sponsorship that we can embed some QR
code in the observation point at the sea
wall so that you'll be able to pick it
up from your smartphone there and then
because its proximity to found this
means that actually ironically enough
the nobod connection is pretty strong
and so you will be able to pick it up
straight away the links unworthy it's
essentially it's essentially YouTube so
it can be it could be sourced from
anywhere so you can be City
or so for at home and look at it or you
can access it directly from the
observation platform and they gain heads
they're also as to enable people with
restricted mobility who perhaps can't
make it to the observation points to
still be able to envisage what the
shipment of look like we'll have it on
display and the main event site to so
that people would really appreciate that
the detail of the 3d generated imagery
there's an interesting thing we are
talking about car park and the
observation platform I was a little bit
confused with that in as much it was
saying that no so the as part of the
capital works that were approved back in
December of last year the council is
making a grant to RSPB to install the
viewing platform at the observation
point and a new car park and a culvert
which will allow people to access the
car pop the these are lasting legacy
assets which will say on the island and
which is why the important thing about
having the CGI is that again is its
legacy it continues over to the event is
finished the the car park on site will
be essentially used for our event space
or as part of beacon event rather than
product car parking but after the event
is practically moved on that pop up more
available
be able to continue to microscopy what
you're saying about the tickets I was
just curious about the tickets how does
that work so is it you buy your ticket
and then you pop or can anyone say
you're just wrong no no no absolutely
access will only be buy a ticket that we
are going to subscribe to Eventbrite
professional package when you choose to
buy a ticket you will have a drop-down
menu which allows you to decide which
car park you would like to travel from
and and that will timeout when is widget
it's it's actual allocation and will
tell you all time you should be means to
be there the information that that
application brings it can be accessed
digitally which means that volunteers
and on-site will be able to be covered
information from a smartphone or from an
iPad some people get to QR code in and
and wristbands can be produced then so
everybody will have everybody like a
wristband and that wristband essentially
will act as their ticket and that
wristband will tell you which bus you
are on what your calm Park you are and
what time the return journey is so it
has literally
that's right and we are on it so from an
event management perspective we will
know where anybody is at any particular
point in that Jeff Smith I've seen I've
seen the evolution of this project but
to be blunt I've I just don't get it I
just don't get it as a successful
project I can see some of the individual
things have got some value and a viewing
platform and wirelessly that'll be
useful in the back of all I reused but I
just don't see this as a as a viable
project
I think ticket sales 2,000 pound 2,000
people a day I just fired pie in the sky
to have a working capital of 50,000 and
then an underwriter 50,000 on top of
that I can see this this event costing
us a a a great deal of money I
understand about the Heritage and so on
but I've talked about a lot of people
and so - perhaps it's sad but I think
most of the district a beagle is at all
they don't know it they don't know about
being lit doesn't mean anything to them
it's not being moderated yes we're going
to to raise the profile
heritage but it doesn't mean anything to
people I I just don't see the appeal in
what is presented to children at all and
I hear some of the the innovative uses
of technology and so on but they don't
strike me as captivating activities I
just don't feel at this moment in time
it is safe to allocate that amount of
money to cover this project because I'm
not convinced that the proposal that I'm
seeing in front of me is one that can be
will be successful clearly if there are
lots of commercial organizations that
that sign up to this and money comes
flooding it then I'm quiet I readily eat
humble pie but I'm just not getting this
and I can't see it being successful I
think that the the costs that are
suggested in terms of in terms of
pricing are way how to counter to what
what people
okay and the range of activities that
are there are just not innovative
exciting or inclusive enough to make
people want to go and although there's a
proposal put forward about parking and
transport I think too many people
that'll just put them off
sorry that's that's how I'm feeling
right now
yeah it might vary quite strongly as
assigned actually what concerns around
the pricing structure feel very
particular in terms of the price for
family attending there I've also have
done bit of research in terms of who is
that as a family we're going to on
Saturday on Sunday we're going to get
tickets all of us to Gary Densham
Islands Forum which pounds because
number organizations like this or the
reduce price which goes into base-jump
two hours for kids that pounds all those
things are established projects that we
know against that we know that the kids
would get some accounts of it would be
wings play up to that was a figure when
I tested event that we've never heard of
before we never been there before
and Papa months maybe see a few birds
and wasn't very successful to be honest
it's elastic bands put up thirty-six
pounds aside to go to someone that you
can get into for free I think it has
been before sticking point for a number
of families and that's a key demographic
that once we get me to this event we do
put more Goods Daye and that's a free
event we get mats
one day we think of how difficult it's
been to actually try and increase the
costs around a Leben
and yet here we're going to be charging
families thirty-six pounds potentially I
just don't think we're going to get the
tickets nice but we're looking for
unless what the seriously look at the
pricing structure because families don't
have that level of disposable income
when I certainly won't be prepared to
spend on an event that's in its first
year because it's not being a chance to
build a neighbor's here now it's a
one-off event but that in itself is a
risk factor so I'm just maybe the
questions again please they want this to
fail but I can't say [ __ ] from that
volume of tickets loose grant process
so just to be clear the mandate I was
given was to make it possible for cost
recovery so the the 50k is it's not 50 K
and 50 K it's a 50k working capital
which allows me to deliver the project
and recover it as part of the sales and
brant etc so the risk is is one of
cashflow Alice's on deputies demand risk
that's what I've suggested that there is
a breakpoint
in October September October to
establish how well we've done I take
entirely the point that this is a unique
and therefore untested but the people
that I've spoken to like that because it
is something it is something different
we are specifically curating things for
small people to do there is stuff that
is educative and there is stuff that is
outdoors there is stuff that is fun it's
stuff that is interactive but we're also
looking to target the local historian
and the academic as well as that we're
looking to make this an authentic
experience and knowledge to you know to
trivialize in
anyway so we have two quantities to try
and strike that balance because I think
we are looking to be part of the British
science festival so it's it is not gel
it is not just a family fun day and it
is serving that educational purpose as
well at the end of the day members it is
entirely a matter fee whether you
decided wish to support this project the
the challenge in scaling it down is that
the pop right aspect of it is as I said
earlier the single biggest cost
contributor so the balance is about
getting the right amount of attractions
on site that will keep people engaged
and attractive for a period of time that
they're there and give them both value
for money and value for time we are
hoping to use the park and ride as part
of the experience
so volunteers will be trained to get
guided tours on the buses to engage with
with the passengers and to encourage
them to look out the window next you
promote a miniature tour of the district
as they go along and to create a sort of
games party festival feel and the the
challenge this were the catch-22 that I
have is that's why boy although I have
collected together a number of people
who are very interested in supporting
we'll continue to who will want to
promote and be associated with it I
can't actually sign them up until this
mean there's green lights to do so
[Music]
appendix its independence it's all good
about gaijin they can be a big boss I
killed me is there anything that we do
it's going to the skull say and we say
well I've been approached by a couple of
PTA representatives who are interested
I've certainly said that in terms of
engaging them a lot of the poster
competition
that's an easy one that we can do fairly
early on I'm happy to do assemblies and
and other things to Tractor talking
about it what it is I've arranged a sale
return arrangement with a publisher of
children's books which explains the
story of the vehicle of the role of and
Charles Darwin the Sedgwick Museum in
Cambridge have a whole series of
educating to interpretation which is
designed specifically for the children
teaching them about the story of the
people and the geological fight
stolen found in her
expeditions what do you put your pricing
structure it might be why people might
be worth money put psyche in its website
fur to school absolutely
few much before handing you know
discount and you know you what people
comes the this is the critical path is
is the is the event management plan so
if that event management plan is is
signed off in December then I'll be
doing a launch in February there's a
certain amount of theater associated
with the reveal on an event like this so
the campaign for publicity in the run-up
to the launch is about is its proposed
to focus each week on a particular
contributor to the event to create a
sense of expectation and to a spot on
sponsors and contributors so that
everything starts to get a sense of what
the
the event is about the simple fact of
the matter is is that the report in
front of you is just a fraction of the
amount of detail that sits be behind
that but it's only a draft at president
so usually actors the advertising going
to the kids getting kids kids getting
everything so I can get the variant
society yeah I mean for example the
University of Essex a 15 stage school
has me to provide some actors to act out
Coast Guard and Watchmen vignettes
across the site sword fights and that
kind of things also you will annuity
excites younger people and the the RSPB
are encouraging young children to the
young explorers themselves and to
explore the the world around them and to
explore nature and to pick up on the
science through observation just just
one thing just following on from what
was just said I mean obviously one of
the things that was very interesting
because about coastline was how
important the revenue men were yeah now
have you contacted each other with
regard to prevent being in joking apart
because obviously the revenue men
bearing in mind that we say here the
beaver was used in in a role with regard
to combating smuggling oh yes it's cuz
nobody then it would be the revenue men
who
very much involved in that particular
task
so the it's difficult to see the angle
that would make it interesting the
taxman comes for an event but I do take
your point the Coast Guard is involved
the marine police unit is involved and
the are in their line then police
Israeli the fire service water rescue
team are really interested in telling
the story of modern smuggling I can
certainly reach out to other government
bodies once through those established
links and certainly the Coast Guard is
is has all been to providing the
additional introduction so they maybe
they can get something I think the
revenue people still Petraglia very
quite still it's very actively
absolutely all defaults gained are on
it's just a different type of smuggling
as to the brandy would have been
of unity is clear but if there is a will
to move forward with this I would say at
this point I don't think I'd be prepared
to support more than 25,000 in working
capital and then dependent on the
progress there nothing comes October we
mentioned is that the next date see that
as a as a next possible from this point
but I do think at this point with what's
in front of us with the feeling that our
become fully in any way
so are you making that proposal
[Music]
I'd go less of her never found it was
still work a woman but Wow even after
what I've said I've reluctantly moved
that that working capital is reduced
down to 25,000 and with the and at this
moment in time the underwrite be twenty
five thousand as well subject to review
its next any presentation what's the
data say
certainly okay well okay so just want to
offend you but the moment the earth
which is 15,000
so that is capital and that is that is
money that was commissioned very set
aside probably two financial years ago
certainly lasts financially it has been
rolled forward to this year so that is
in there is separate so this this
they've cut the budget for this event is
fifty thousand and so I'm just looking
forward all down up to that amount but I
take countless it's like comment
cleanly the simple fact of the matter is
is I wouldn't be drawing down because
the the lion's share is for ticket sales
I wouldn't be drawing down the amount of
committed cost would be significantly
less than the 50,000 to leave median to
our many concerns regarding the melting
his house if this could be done at no
cost
families
it was paid for by businesses
I'm supposed to talk to them
we would be in total cost of somewhere
in the nation of 34,000 pounds
that's what else
without the mountainous rates for ticket
sales you
if we regretted the 25 does that enable
you to carry on we certainly will enable
me to get to September October and to
review it at that yes - any other
questions
okay in that case then I'll have to take
the recommendations one by one item 1.1
tastes like to be the vengeance of
silver project reported through the
counselors project program immense
profits are we agreement in that and
item 1.2 to improve the drawdown of
25,000 from earmark resist provide a
working capital budget for the beagle
event in accordance with the budget and
funding plan set out in confidential
appendix a is everybody happy with that
to underwrite the cost of enter of up to
25,000 if this cannot be fully recovered
from the project income streams of
ticket sales and sponsorship I might
have one point for the draught event
management plan associated with quality
impact assessments are appointed to the
executive before the event metal plan is
subject to the regional Safety Advisory
Group pretty happy that it could just
have obviously September October yes is
one were looking to River to review and
I've set out I'm still to be convinced
and I see up October September October
not just as a staging post but as a
proper review of how the project is
likely to succeed or not I just felt
it's fair to say that at this point in
time he having with that
just as a slight side issue I would like
to perhaps see some publicity to our
residents around this I've visited Italy
around Wakering barley and firmness a
considerable number of properties and
the amount of claims that I've come
across to people having lumps of the
people in their kitchens and in their
lounges and things it would be
interesting to have a little bit of
publicity around to see if people what
to register so certainly the there is a
communications plan which we have
thought up jointly with the RSPB
which includes a various stages of the
campaign as a village too early
including 8 event will be intercepted
Roger Roger
meeting and certainly will be looking to
you as the 20 X 20 20 communications
ramped up to two branch as possible
actually say yes
I consume
but for the assistant director assets
and commercial with regards to the
leisure cultural strategy exact report
is quite straightforward but just by way
of introduction the counsel pleasure and
top services team the robot wide range
of services including but not limited to
management of rated windmill key
attraction for the district while would
today of course an annual family events
managing and developing the council's
civil ceremony service at our posture
you've been you sleep really well and
the elder housing in Rockford and also
delivery a very small events activities
in client ship but other other other
services networks and obviously
crucially monitoring and accounts elijah
contract the team has their seen many
successes in achievements it's time many
which Shire own are listed in the report
members the leisure and cultural service
of strategy will ensure a clear
direction for the council's leisure in
call for services team it will sets out
its priorities and aspirations but
crucially aligning them with our partner
strategies and priorities the strategy
itself it seeks to be aspirational and
vicious and innovative we're looking to
maximize opportunities also facilitates
effective collaborative working
it has a clear vision for that
collaborative an aspirational approach
to support the people of all ages to be
an active and healthy life known across
our district the drafting of the
strategy took place with consultation of
internal colleagues external partners
groups portfolio holding for community
for play hard for enterprise and also
crucially some other groups and networks
such as active Botsford the green tea
activity network in the district the
County Sports Partnership active Essex
colleagues in the health sector and the
education sector and school sports
partnership to get a real feel for the
key drivers across our district a bit
for this service the work completed
through that identified some key
strengths and challenges the service
needs to overcome resulting in four
strategies sorry four priorities is set
on strategy folks being legislators
provision partnerships and networks
commercial and a heritage focus the
properties themselves will be supported
by detailed annual delivery plans and I
started a team are already working
previous good work Cheerilee closing
it's a hopefully a straight board
reports happy to answer any questions
the strategy will be crucial as I've
said it in setting that clear direction
for the team and also setting out the
authority to the future works in that
key team all right the counselor service
does port fighters hopper capsule will
push to everything's left yeah it's like
thanks to that and the marketing team
for putting together an excellent
strategy it's laid out very clearly and
ambitions of the district for many years
and we took I think it's it's groundwork
very nicely for the future service to
interact I think it is crucial that we
are head of the game in terms of new
contracts on page and page seven six
hundred fifty thousand visits to campus
or the moment purchase entering eighty
ninety is its contracts it needs to be
one enter this gives us an extra
foundation
that's me
like to endorse the comments counts the
way I think that the strategy does
exactly what it needs to do it sets out
where where we want to go and as you say
it's it's the early steps of our
thoughts about the new leisure contract
but somehow the failure feel the need to
say how strategically important this is
to us because the side of the bin
contract that figure on page 7 at 7.10
of 650,000 visits to Clements hall gives
an indication of how many people across
our district and further afield this is
going to influence I mean obviously
there's multiple visits in that but when
you're talking of those sorts of numbers
clearly this is this is going to have an
impact in so many families in so many
homes in so many different ways and we
need to view this not as an important
Ministry of exercise that we're doing we
need to see it as something that is key
to the way in which this council will be
viewed by its residents because if we
get this wrong
or possibly don't appreciate its
significance and potentially impact on
that number of people I think the the
the pitfalls the hurdles were however
you would choose to describe it are
massive so the strategy does exactly
what it needs to do but as it continues
to evolve or we get to the next stage I
would like to see more that reflects the
strategic importance of this to the
council because with it if it if it goes
off and I think as a council we fail
thank you very much I just want a center
actually on the window because only as
personally out with a group of
volunteers we've got a three moon jump
funding round I'm actually going to be
going
there and I was very disappointed at how
the local area and the synergy of the
room the poorly cared for these we work
very hard to clear weeds and things that
surrounding air leading up to it from
the mill into the window around the
windmill I feel that as an area that
we're having it's published as effluent
filling a great backdrop for photographs
for things like that I think it's really
important that it shouldn't look shabby
and to me payment of weeds coming out
all the full round it looks shattered in
my opinion and then we've done as good a
job as we could yesterday to a lot of
hours you know six of us volunteers
trying to do that work which in my
opinion should be done all year round by
you know I mean whoever maintains you
whoever supposed to maintain it I don't
know about the other facilities I've
done about the outhouse of how well that
is maintained I notice it's right within
the council edifice and so obviously as
you plant your seat if it's unkempt or
it's not nice and nobody goes plant that
rural area in my opinion to inspect and
look at it and it's a bike show because
I was looking at in closer quarters and
it was very disappointed with
it's a forest possession and we should
be treasuring it and we should be
looking after it better that it is
currently available that's that's my
take on it
Jared just say I've got great women was
a key asset that set out and the
strategy it's a very successful scenario
venue and I'll take out the grass mates
issue with colleagues on about episode
you very much cataract thank you I hear
what you're saying
and one of those people that's been out
there yeah but I do agree with most of
what you're saying
however and and places like the windmill
should look prestige because you know
it's one about Big Island and but I can
tell you whenever I run Marcus or
Carolina immediately they've had someone
out now whether this should be a matter
of fact and things should be doing in
you know as a matter as a matter of
or whether they I don't know what's
lacking there but I do know when we ring
them they are very good at going out
they've been out I've sent a team out
there today yes and it looks good back
there but maybe we're just you know I
don't really think this is the right
place for the right forum for that
conversation I think we should be taking
this up however I do I hear what you're
saying and I hear these kind of places
should look the stage all times but my
thanks do go to the team today because
they've been out there and done
everything we've asked them to do that's
audience thank you I think this is Delta
Council and we have a spot anomaly here
waiting is believe it or not I know that
in houses
but it is his judgment so I got to hurry
back for night it's around the surrounds
of the river itself I don't know whose
property is that restoration skill to
capture truly now they've got think that
his audience is out and that's the point
fotona is the area which needs
maintenance any other questions yes sir
I'm greatly for I'm looking that's a
item 7b 70 level we look in that
I visit all activities levels allowed in
waffles now you talking about the name
to farmers are we talking to partners
are actually good with with the physical
activity levels to actually what we do
involved where our national average is
physical activity low national average
and that be cities about the national
averages average of Matra community we
do better so I am I think that the
stretcher refers to networks being a
poverty which is the exclusively human
our farmers willing to him with the help
of being bored through their strategy to
the community activity network massive
Rochford sorry active assets the
countable sponsorship they have
strategies that we link into looking at
best practices we after the name Stern
funding our daily initiative initiatives
out as we can tie into working with
other supporters so those the priorities
and there are some challenges there we
to make sure we're linked into those
networks we access that best practice we
roll that out past weekend
I agree those two challenges is we plant
in the detail obesity it's in their
mental health well-being torso and
there's two key priorities which we
mirror from the body
that's all yes thank you very much then
that's it
what an interesting point as far as I'm
concerned I just wanted I've been
thinking with any other private gym the
yoga classes all the various things that
are going on around the town do we have
the link you were there to understand
because we're gonna figure here 15.9%
items of the you know are only doing
down there national language is 1746 are
we just looking at what we do within the
leisure center and the people who go
there as presented for their population
or have we actually taken do we have any
idea of how many people or using private
facilities and other facilities
terms of that the best data for activity
levels is active people server computer
bicycles in today carry on an annual
survey where they ring present another
actually produce reams and reams of data
that we actually link into so that
faster probably the the most effective
months because we use our data and it
gives us a range of areas to target
again that that the feed instance
process as well the sporting will be a
key and salty going forward so that kind
of set into account yes yeah it's the -
the main decks of what were you the
other questions okay
said one item 1.1 a recommendation then
and seek approval for the leisure and
cultural strategy 2019 to 2024 at second
one is everybody approved that we switch
the on to item 8
council project program mental disease
chair I think doing the report is
self-explanatory but colleagues why
don't I write down here in English right
now I think reporter self-explanatory
but colleagues my left my right are here
if they have any questions
jessalyn thank you I just actual members
attention to like what certainly a black
hand is that page number 8 second line
down to milestone change of them make
music here be all right yes just like
strong members attention so if I can
return attempt this makes it work around
this reducing the number of families in
BMV I think it's just worth recognizing
that we've now under fire ourselves in
B&B in July Thank You Marcus
introduction numbers it's June 2017 I
spend on one of the cheese the
franchisee takes over in 2017
you know that's fine it's all just like
secularism the TV like is and that's a
benefit to us and say thank you talking
to a number of other councils as I did
over the OPA
they are very jealous of our fingers so
very well done very well done
any other questions therapy teams hate
practically yes and we spoke with the
developers today
but he is moving forward it's moving
forward and the developers have been
committed to the site
our city
I must have meant from the square side
when you look at the building it doesn't
look as if much is happening it's still
looking a bit scruffy and what-have-you
so it would be nice to see absolutely
there were some of that so that we can
see something happening I mean we've
seen their work schedule mortise
appropriate for what they need to do at
the moment is will happen in time
exactly
it's the odd boarded up windows it still
looks a bit of damage it's just I guess
is it [ __ ] but by the end of this year
where we've got various houses have been
built coming forward and the allocations
that will come forward in regards to
happen I put it for use as far as our
own people are concerned with the churn
going on when we get rid of those people
now TMA and move them into the temporary
accommodation and then those in
temporary accommodation actually coming
into the housing lives that's maybe
taking over from children housing and
watch that housing those do we
anticipate that we can clear that
cleared the expiration but I can't say
we need some inspiration that we would
get to zero be a big that's our target
ask us project there are a lot of
unnoticed at the moment were just work
to sustain the level that we've got we
have to understand that
you get zero to be a be that you'll
still have a constant evening but thank
you
so it's it's not I mean and that's one
target but it was see that's about the
targets in it
we do a spine to zero at the moment we
reduce significantly in the amount
staying
turn around
you know
mr. Smith I'll just refer to one project
in our ward we just um towards a
strategy and that was working with a lot
of our partners the conversion of
Francisco Z large when that was proposed
the outcry was huge the accusations
about what it would become
and the type of people that would be put
on there were quite outrageous they
didn't seem to be any living to the the
tales that would be told about what this
place would turn into well I did the
projects now done delivered a drop I go
past this on on a regular basis and I
don't see the drug dealers all queuing
up outside I don't see the lines of
Alcoholics them standing outside as we
were told to expect
I see a a well-kept well-maintained
facility doing a fantastic job for the
district and what I don't hear is all
those people that were moaning and
making the accusation accusations
they've got mysteriously very very quiet
indeed it's a great success and I'm
really proud to have it I think
everybody should be adorable correct
lighted on that
take the flak on it
okay real pleasure to present amor where
we've got the change control before the
pharmacist that one there we've got the
first one we we've got new host now on
two-year fixed contract they've worked
in working know what they would come
after review would we as a manual
permanent if they saving this money
going in and started coming out this on
at the moment there's that
production that all that fun things
we have obviously
- for us to consider an album
so those members of staff have actually
reduced the amount I'm getting so
prevention officers or prevention
officers on that bridge and say that's
about
it just gives you an idea earlier
it's the best to say
the approach that we take
the other questions
but but on page eight point one we have
the apartment 3
I recommend I see I eat my 38.3 item
11.1 propose that the executive resolved
to note the contents of he own dashboard
everybody that brings us to the end of
this meeting
thank you a buddy for coming along thank
you
you